quantum computing related and the first
talk is by defang who will tell us about
algorithms for
quantum hamiltonian simulation
all right thank you so much for the
introduction and thank you everyone for
coming to the talk so uh basically uh if
that my understanding is correctly uh is
correct then i think that the the
purpose of the workshop is to introduce
myself to you guys so um in that sense
this slide is perhaps the most important
size of my talk so as you can see my
name is default so please feel free to
call me my mathematicians is in both the
math department as well as the simon's
uh research for quantum computing and
this figure that i created basically
summarized my research areas i work in
the intersection between mathematics and
quantum especially when there is a
computing aspect to it so specifically
actually i am trained in numerical
analysis as well as stem classical
analysis that's a type of pde analysis
and i work on these pde problems with
application to quantum science so um the
specific type of interest
that i i'm working on can be summarized
into the three different types of
quantum problems number one is classical
algorithm for quantum dynamics number
two is quantum algorithm for classical
problems such as say uh uh classical
differential equations and uh and a
learning task and then uh the talk uh
the focus of the talk today is quantum
algorithm for quantum dynamics which is
uh uh what i'm going to briefly discuss
all right uh as i realized that there
are only two talks uh in our workshop
regarding quantum so i'm going to do a
really sort of uh naive if my quantum
friends are yin i mean expert quantum
friends in the audience you may be not
as happy with me but we can certainly
discuss afterwards so i plan just to do
a little bit of super quick high level
overview of quantum computing starting
with computing 101 and then just tells
you what is the problem that i want to
deal with and what is the difficulty and
i and the fact that i i did it
without uh discussing more of the
detailed analysis of it all right so
let's start with this a very a very
famous uh richard fema's quote well i
think it's a consensus in quantum
community if you give a general talk you
should have a female figure somewhere in
the talk so here is it uh the point is
that if we talk about the original
motivation of quantum computing it can
be dated back to this the 80s the story
is basically that if we think about
nature it really acts quantum
mechanically which is terribly high
dimension and has impossible i mean
physical for classical computer to
handle then uh female basically suggests
that if that's the case then why do we
may cover a computational device quantum
so that it acts quantum mechanically
hopefully we have the right degrees of
freedom to work on this problem so
essentially what fema suggests is to
look at this quantum stimulation problem
also called hamiltonian simulation
problem the setup is really simple uh we
are just giving us a certain description
of the habitonian which can be time
dependent and the purpose of the task is
basically we want to produce a final
state up to certain procedure
mathematically we circle we can
certainly write down the differential
equation which is just a strategic
equation and as some examples of this
hamiltonian for example it can be a
laplacian potential where the laplacian
is a connective part and potential is
the interaction for example if we talk
about molecular dynamics there's this
multiple body schrodinger equation and
this x you should view it as terribly
high dimension in the sense that for
molecule if we have uh we have electrons
and nuclei if the total number is at her
then the the dimensionality of this
problem is three atta and that's how
long you discretize it in each of the
dimensions it's not terribly high
dimension so curse of dimensionality is
of course someone something one should
worry all right then the task of a
habitonian simulation is really simple
um suppose h is time independent we can
write easily write out this exact
unitary which is just the exact solution
uh the task of hamiltonian simulation is
that we can we want to construct
approximate unitary that can be
efficiently implemented on common
computer by efficient i will explain
very soon what we mean by the efficiency
so that
when measuring battery certain norm
we can get certain procedures so this is
it very simple to to explain well uh on
the other hand if h is time dependent
the story is really the same just that
you have an integral you have a time
ordering term but nevertheless the story
is really the same all right so uh now
let's talk about why and why first of
all what why quantum computer uh well
fema says something uh you'd better try
it but if there's no practical mirrors
then maybe you shouldn't pour money into
this field so i'm going to just give a
really um oversimplified not so accurate
uh sort of a high-level idea of what a
quantum computer is if you think about
quantum computer maybe this is what
pop-up in my your mind this is one of
google's quantum computer you may think
that quantum computer is this super
dedicated piece of device that causes
your volume to make then point is why
right
um
as an oversimplified
picture uh from scientific
computing point of view i'm just going
to say that for the purpose of the talk
that i'm going to say quantum computer
is this device that can calculate this
matrix vector multiplication this matrix
operations super fast you may wonder how
fast is fast if we just directly do the
calculation then we know that the cos is
going to be n squared if you think about
what is the the most uh celebrated uh
algorithm last century is going to be uh
arguably the fft phosphoric transform
what that's basically do is that for
certain structures of a instead of n
squared you can get n log n so you get
almost linear that is very significant
you may wonder what does quantum
computer bring on the table that they
got rid of this log and maybe make n
square root and what's the
what's the gaining the gaining is that
it's actually getting rid of the end so
it's actually this long skating that's
why people are so um excited about it
this potential exponential power gaining
from quantum computer
all right then now why uh hamiltonian
simulation as we said that it serves as
our original motivation of the quantum
computer certainly coming from physics
it has great physical and chemical
application and what i won't also want
to say is that this is actually
a very commonly used subroutine for many
quantum algorithms such as matrix
inversion as you can see uh there are
many applications scientifically uh as
well all right so uh just uh i won't
tell you the uh i mean there are great
many of uh advances recently in this uh
in this field
i won't tell you i won't discuss the
details of all these methods but the
message is that the underlying
difficulty of the problem actually
increases when the problem becomes more
and more highly authentic so suppose
this h has a very large norm as we know
that this exponential negative i uh i i
ht is wrapping around by itself super
fast so this is a one source of
hydrosity the other source is on top of
that if t
hamiltonian is time dependent it's very
fast they uh very fast then there's a
second source of hydraulic surgery
existing algorithm typically have a
polynomial dependence of of the cause or
either one of them so for the simplicity
of the talk let's forget about the
derivative for the moment and just talk
about operation norm of h all right so
uh the major takeaway is that this is a
typical cost that uh shares by uh all of
the algorithm
it has some polynomial dependence on uh
uh
this operator norm of h under this
polynomial where there is number of
cubits in the problem which is the log
size of the hero space so this is uh
what we got is polylog i just want to
say that for bounded hamiltonian
simulation so if a hamiltonian
simulation where h is bounded operator
this story is already complete the best
no algorithm already matches the experi
i mean the
the the the the theoretical lower bound
so the story is already complete uh what
the talk for today is that we are going
to discuss what about our body operator
apparently you can see that if the
problem the operator is unbounded this
guy is going to be infinity so if you
talk about the cost this guy will
overcome this uh uh polylog and will
become the dominant part of the course
actually it's actually infinity that
how how can you actually even talk about
the cost
well you can certainly ask me well find
the uh while the operator the norm is
infinity but why should i even care is
there any application if i really look
at this problem the answer is certainly
yes this is a molecular dynamics i just
put some graph to entertain my audience
this is electronic structure problem and
this is some recent machine learning
tasks that can be already uh represented
in this form a laplacian plus potential
laplacian is on bonded it's operational
amazing
you can still argue with me that d i
never like even on classic computer we
never directly simulate our body
operator we always
discretize it must discrete uh after
discretization isn't the norm it's just
a finite constant why should i even care
so that's just illustrating a super
naive one-dimensional case you can see
that the size of the hyperspace is
capital letter n and the operator norm
of this this make uh this hamiltonian h
is also popular router and this will
give you a cost that is polyem but
remember the goal is really polylock so
this is uh what is the challenge comes
here so i i hope that the uh i i gave
you enough motivation of what is a major
challenge and why this is a different uh
this is a meaningful question to study
and uh the question is the the the the
main question is really how to get rid
of this strong uh independence hopefully
make it long and the answer is yes i
won't go into like how i construct the
algorithm what is the the the circuit
construction what is the complexity
analysis just to tell you the answer is
yes we can do that and we also have a
very surprising super convergence
results that's highly not trivial and i
won't have time to discuss that you are
very welcome to discuss with me
afterwards so this is a complexity these
are all these are no empirical bounds
these are uh i mean analysis bounds and
you can see that our algorithm also
performs in terms of this specific
component operator task or performs uh
all the state-of-the-art uh bounds of
existing algorithms all right
uh just to say that this particular pro
quest uh the algorithm that i talked
about q-hop is actually remember i said
there are two oscillations the other
oscillation come from if uh there is a
chi dependency in the hamiltonian so we
also want the derivative dependence
maybe be going to be log so our
algorithm actually check this box as
well so it's actually the first
algorithm can simultaneously handle
these two problems so it's especially
valuable if we have a body operator so
uh with that that's pretty much my talk
and this is the uh the main result that
i discussed this is another result which
i said previous results in the in in the
table and these are the some of the two
recent work where we propose a
so-called observable error bounce which
is a framework analysis that can give
you further improvements if you look at
hamiltonians on both the operators with
uh base uh in the setting of molecular
dynamics so with that i want to thank
you for your attention if you are
interested in knowing me more you are
welcome to discuss or you can check my
web page and that's it thank you
thank you very much for the talk
questions yeah
so i have two questions uh first
question um
the first question is regarding the
result where you mentioned with the
unbounded operator is that only applied
to the case where the uh it has needs to
have a laplacian operator there or it's
like general unbounded yeah that's a
good question so actually you can handle
any the case of there is a polynomials
of the derivative so as long as a pde
and actually this laplacian plus
potential as i show in the picture is
actually the physical ones so you can
handle the cases where there's a
polynomial of the momentum operator can
be multiplied by some time dependent
control terms and plus say the the
potential which has a time dependent
part as well or say molecular dynamics
there's a no time dependency either way
this is a actually uh interesting
problem to study and i think a relevant
issue is also that
we know that in general it's impossible
to improve regarding this operator norm
if you we consider arbitrary the the the
reason we can improve on this particular
say this physical hamiltonian is because
it's not a general result say for any
arbitrary hamiltonian because for any
arbitrary hamiltonian it's guaranteed by
no probability zero we know that there
is a lower bound you cannot go over this
polynomial dependence of the the the
norm of it so it's really using the
structure of the problem to gain uh
actual better results
okay maybe the next speaker can
set up and uh someone else's questions
what was that supposed to
like you had a cat next to the logo oh
it's a it's a short interest cat it just
uh yeah
just uh
yeah just the most famous character
[Music]
any other question
okay if not for the final talk of the
session quantum scientific computation
by jinping